another show i really recommend
murderville
on netflix oh peep
yeah did you did you watch it yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] funny it's it's i've
never seen this format before yeah
i don't know you can tell me if you've
seen anything like this before i'll just
describe it really briefly it's like
it's like a scene
and will arnett like plays this
detective
and everyone is an actor but they're all
like improv artists as well but they all
know the scene and the lines generally
what's supposed to happen in the scene
and then there's a celebrity guest who
is will our net's partner got it and
they're the only ones that has no idea
what's going on so they're improving the
whole thing interesting so they all have
like set jokes and stuff that they know
they're gonna make and then
they just break and like and they keep
it in
interesting so it's like watching a
scripted show with just one person that
has no idea what's going on that's
pretty good it's pretty and it's like
it's like a you know quintessential like
murder mystery every episode has a
different mystery that the guest has to
solve so at the very end they're like i
think it was this person and the sheriff
comes in and they're like you're wrong
or you're right because of these reasons
so it's like you're kind of trying to
solve it at the same time that's cool
weird like it's really [ __ ] weird and
weird and jung is the last episode and
he just is breaking the entire time like
they [ __ ] with him so much and the whole
time he's just like
[Laughter]
it's so good damn so it's like a
it's like a
improv game show yes
thing with really cheesy
uh like csi puns and stuff like that got
it
yeah perfect the only thing he'll be
does um today is murder yeah okay
great i started watching them but and
then well sorry
they like purposely set them up to like
like in the uh episode with uh god
[ __ ] what's his name
uh god damn it bill clinton dude who got
it was silicon valley guy got super
[ __ ] jacked
[Music]
he uh in one of the episodes um will
arnett is like all right like they're
confronting this
high school jock they're at will's like
uh high school reunion and they like got
to confront the chalk and he's like all
right we have to make sure that we're
cool they can't he can't know that we're
detectives or he's not going to talk to
us so like show me a cool walk
camille's like what he's like just show
me like a cool walk right now right one
two three go
and camille's like okay and he's like
he's like no no pretend like you have
rubber bands connected to your arms and
so he'll just make them do this
yeah that's [ __ ] good so watch that
show it's funny
i've watched like three episodes of the
tom and pam [ __ ]
for tommy and pam like tommy lee oh i
thought that was good
the
dialogue in that is so atrocious yeah i
mean but it's like on purpose
i get what they're trying to do but it's
like this halfway like it's in between
like a modern tv show and like
uh like because hulu
it's like made for commercial breaks and
stuff so i think they kind of still make
it in the vein of like traditional tv so
i think they add like a little bit of
that cheesy factor right you know minus
tommy lee's dick talking to him but that
i mean i didn't i couldn't even really
watch that scene
[Laughter]
i didn't think it was funny
yeah it was like i just thought it was
[ __ ] weird yeah i got what they were
trying to do i didn't even get it
uh
yeah it was him reflecting like you're
really gonna marry this chick and it was
him
you know yeah his dick being like but
you're yeah like it was him thinking
with his heart he was leading with his
heart for the first time right i don't
know it's just a little bit too
to me i thought it was cracked no i
thought it was a like hilarious i'm like
oh this is like an adult swim sketch in
the middle
of this
you know otherwise very yeah polished tv
show yeah
um
yeah i don't know the
the directing like kills me i feel like
they tell everyone like all right do
what you just did but
more yeah more like oh yeah and it's
just i don't know it just doesn't feel
seth rogen is incredible in that show
though yeah yeah yeah he plays that
character so goddamn well yeah
yeah i think like i just
not to get caught up on the technicals
but i kind of wish i just they just did
like a straight up documentary because i
want to know the real story right i
looked it up a lot of those like
moments
in the first few episodes are
pretty
accurate to what happened yeah yeah i
didn't know that yeah
it's so wild
so so
i had my friend uh from the north shore
come and stay with me this weekend but
you could say i have my friend get a
copy of the tom and pammy you'll be
watching me together
tom and pamela
no but i'm talking about that we're like
pulling up to my place and i was like
and i was like have you seen pam and
tommy he's like no no i haven't seen it
yet but like you know
might go say hi to her tomorrow
what are you talking about like you want
to watch the show and he's like no i'm
like friends with
pamela anderson i was like can i
can i go there
just my inner like 13 year old jumped
out i was like pamela anderson
can i go there and he was like nah he's
like no he said yeah and he texted her
and she was texting but then he had no
service and so he like didn't get her
text for a few hours and if the
opportunity fell through but i [ __ ]
ah i'm watching your documentary on hulu
get the [ __ ] out of my house
get out of here
damn
well
yeah right it's that opportunity yeah
now now tom's with brittney furlin
yep
yeah yeah you didn't know that yeah
they're married yeah they yeah they
[ __ ] on an airplane i know that much
about them why
it was like a thing like a while ago
like they both went into like
you know like into the bathroom on a
flight that was from like
it was like you know three hour flight
so
on a ga flight
yeah or admission yeah yeah
i took a scheduled flight
yeah
damn no it was like the bathroom was
kind of like mid plane
so it was like at the back of like
business class okay
so i mean you can't do that even in
business class no but what i'm saying is
that like super illegal yeah you're not
supposed to but i'm just saying it
wasn't like
you know like they were in first class
and the bathroom was kind of tucked away
and maybe the people up there would like
turn their heads like they just did it
like like on a mid plane [ __ ] ride
from new jersey to ohio wow
and then they just like both like came
out of the bathroom like giggling
covered in jizz yeah literally
yeah i don't even know how you i mean i
guess you can but airplane bathrooms are
so small
yeah i don't know i'd just be scared
that i hit the flusher
and you both threw it yeah yeah exactly
no yeah i'd be scared that i would get
flushed out
no just like the most violent sound on
earth yeah you know it's like nothing
romantic about that sound that would
make me lose my bones
yeah also
you know the airplane bathrooms make me
feel tall
yeah with the curve yeah so i don't know
how you're like gonna like sit like
curved forward
you gotta have a big ass dick probably
or even if you got a little pecker i
mean just the whole thing is just
uncomfortable like you're both gonna be
you know yeah i'm saying but yeah yeah
that's true it's it's still tommy lee
it's probably easier to find a position
that sure works you know yeah yeah me
too my penis like his body goes up to my
forehead
yeah
and when i get hard that's why i
couldn't watch that dick scene yeah
because it's just like it's happened to
me yeah
i've talked to my pen as well all the
time
you